thank you
you know I know how to use it
yeah
Jake
I know
you always wanted to teach me
but I never wanted to learn
I hate guns
I'll tell you because I was always so
afraid of upsetting you
love me more
you know this is your fault
everything
Simon would still be alive right now if
you just hadn't been a [ __ ]
it's on you
none of this would have happened if you
would have just been
loyal to me
I loved you Eddie I even give you a
second chance and now
I'll look at it
really Jake
[Music]
can I just have my backpack
please
okay
let's drop it drop it
drop it
[Music]
hey friend
always looking out for me
foreign
just trying to break us apart man
so we wouldn't find out what you had
done to us
to me
your friend
[Music]
it's nothing against you man
I just want to get rid of the [ __ ]
genius who really believed he could play
me
I'm sorry
and friendly lying
cheating girlfriend
[Music]
it's a shame that nobody thought she was
smart enough to come up with a plan half
as good as mine
so I had to go with plan B frame the
most obvious suspect
you just couldn't let it go could you
huh Jake
well not anymore
give me the Xbox babe
now
[Music]
okay
let's do whatever you want us to do
that's my girl
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you
oh my God
oh
okay
it'll dissolve as soon as you put in
wire
how the [ __ ] did I let you talk me into
this are you bitching out again
everything I've done through expose the
liars and fakes
and I'm about to fake my own
assassination attempt
after blackmailing the only teacher I
like in this damn place
well you could always just go home
back to your
boring [ __ ] life
wondering what if you had the guts to
actually go through with it
and there you
go
the last time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'll see you on the other side
what dumbass
see you on the other side
foreign